hey guys Pete here this is my 10 things
you might have missed in Twin Peaks the
return part 10 if you haven't watched
episode 10 in season 3 yet this will
contain spoilers otherwise let's jump
right into it so we'll start off where
we ended in the recap and review more or
less and that is this letter that deputy
Chad intercepted at the Twin Peaks
Sheriff's Department Miriam had told
Richard that she was sent a letter to
the sheriff sheriff Truman and after his
attempt at killing her he contacted Chad
into him to intercept it now eagle-eye
fans noticed that the last name on the
letter was different than what Miriam
was credited as in the end credit to
different last names and it could be
explained away as you know their maiden
name but she doesn't appear to be
married and yeah everything that kind of
comes up for this to try to explain it
away is pretty weak honestly and I think
there's a possibility that the letter
she sent wouldn't even have gone to the
26 Sheriff's Department she said she
started to share Truman now this is
complete speculation but she said she
had talked to the police didn't know why
she died he hadn't been arrested we
could assume the only way this would
have happened is if she had talked to
Chad and he also didn't file a report if
she is connected with red and Richards
drug business perhaps that means that
she also knows that chad is dirty
especially now that nothing's happened
of the investigation so perhaps instead
of writing to the current sheriff Truman
she might have sent a letter directly to
share a Harry Truman wherever he is like
I said that's complete speculation but
there's a million ways you can go with
it
most of them all end up in that he
probably intercepted the wrong letter
and that's going to cause trouble for
both him and Richard down the road the
next thing is the creepy face on the
bear in front of Johnny Horne is from a
cartoon series I guess you would call it
called dumb land that Dave
instead I hadn't seen it but I did go
and watch it it's quite an entertaining
and funny of course it's weird
but definitely worth a watch but yeah
the main character in dumb land has this
space that I would say a hundred percent
there was fashioned after the next thing
is a lot of the thing that a lot of
people brought up in the comments that
the singer at the Roadhouse this time
was Rebecca Del Rio who was in
Mulholland Drive and that Moby was
playing the guitar in her band so this
musical performance seems to be a
tipping point for some people so I won't
go on and on about it but it's also
interested to note that David Lynch is a
co-writer on the song itself the next
big thing the fourth big thing is that
other guy that's in the picture with
evil coop at the room in New York City
can't say that I've learned anything
more about him since I did the recap and
review but just in case you weren't
glued to the television screen at the
time that Tammy showed Gordon up with
this photo there's clearly another
person in there he could be wearing a
lab coat definitely wearing glasses and
as far as I can tell it's just those two
they're both outside the box and they're
talking if I had to speculate wildly I
would say that the guy in the mystery
guy is explaining how the box works to
evil coop but that's just speculation
the fifth thing you might have missed is
that Richards car and this is just a
funny thing but Richards car obviously
had some Mis colored panels on it his
car actually matches the outfit that
Diane was wearing at the coroner's
office in Buckland
I saw this photo circulating around and
it's pretty funny I mean they I don't
know why it's important it probably
isn't but it's definitely if they shot
the Richard scene first I can totally
see him saying to wardrobe or whatever
hey Diane got to be wearing these colors
and that's where that came from the
sixth thing you might have missed was
that plan to destroy the trailer
probably won't work we saw that he had
knocked her out she was bleeding me
that is and that his plan was to light
the candle after he turned on the oven
and opened the door but he kicked out
the front window so there's clearly
ventilation plus it looks like if you
look at the trailer
there's probably air circulation in
there in the first place
so don't write off Miriam as being dead
yet
does it matter well I obviously would if
she is still alive but we won't know
until we know the next thing is really
just a glitch I think at this point
there was a lot of talk about when Tammy
is walking down the hall to show the
photo to Gordon and Albert that she's in
slow motion and it's pretty clear that
the the door frame like the handle area
there's something going on with it when
she approaches quite a few people who
work in film or editing weighed in on
this though and it does sound like it's
probably just a post-production like
software glitch so that's what made the
most sense to me in other words when
they put her in slow motion like that it
creates you know they use a piece of
software to create extra frames to make
it look extra slow and this can cause
problems other places which I think
that's all it is
now the fact that she's walking in slow
motion is a whole different thing as far
as the door glitch as it's been referred
to I think it is just that I think it's
a mistake that isn't really important
beyond that the a thing that you might
have missed or might not have thought
about Johnny's bear is talking to him it
says hello Johnny
how are you today over and over again
you didn't miss that but something that
you might not have thought of I know I
didn't right at the beginning was the
connection that Johnny had with Laura
you'll remember that she did come over a
few times a week to read to him and he
was devastated when he found out about
her death well before that from some of
the stuff in her secret diary that they
put out it turns out that they actually
had a pretty close relationship and not
in the normal sense those like they
talked or anything but she cared for him
she got something out of doing it he
obviously did
it leads to some interesting places if
you look into it like she believed that
he chose to be silent because it was
more interesting that way then she
actually ended up seeing dr. Jacoby
because Johnny was a patient of his and
dr. Jacoby has thoughts on it - he
thinks that Johnny reverted because
something really bad happened to him
some sort of trauma and so he reverted
to this childlike state so it kind of
gives a little bit of context to Johnny
and why he might be back it could be
completely unrelated to Richard horn or
anything else so yeah it's pretty
interesting it's um it's worth a look if
you haven't read anything about it the
next thing that you might have missed
the Laura seen that when Gordon goes to
the door and he sees Laura before he
sees Albert that is the scene from fire
walk with me Laura goes over to Donna's
place and she's hysterical
this is after she saw Leland go home and
that's what made it click about the
diary so yeah this was she was
traumatized he goes over and she's like
Donna are you my best friend and it's
pretty crazy scene now it could be just
there because of the way it looks in the
way that it fit with what they were
doing I'm not sure if it's got any
deeper meaning but feel free to
speculate away in the comments if you
think there's anything to this because
it's pretty fascinating I mean it's
fascinating Gordon Ernestine vision it
doesn't seem like it's supposed to be a
memory so yeah it's kind of neat and
it's definitely mysterious so let's talk
about it and the final thing that you
might have missed the beloved log lady
in her message and the name of the
episode was Laura is the one that
someone had commented in my last video
that they had just watched those log
lady intros and that she says that in
those and those intros are on the on the
box set but they basically filmed an
intro for just about every episode if
not every episode whereas the log lady
kind of introduced it before it came on
I think they were filmed for maybe a
European release or something like that
or it could have been I don't know I
didn't look into it I've seen these
before and I read them all but I didn't
look into where they air
if anywhere else besides the DVDs but
anyways this was the introduction to the
pilot she told you who she is she says
she's from Twin Peaks she's known as the
log lady and then she goes on to say
that there are many stories in Twin
Peaks some of them are sad some funny
some of them are stories of madness of
violence some are ordinary yet they all
have about them a sense of mystery the
mystery of life
sometimes the mystery of death the
mystery of the woods the woods
surrounding Twin Peaks to introduce this
story let me just say it encompasses the
all it is beyond the fire the few would
know that meaning it is a story of many
but it begins with one and I knew her
the one leading to the many is Laura
Palmer Laura is the one so that is where
that came from and it's very interesting
very interesting and mysterious to say
the least
so what do you think it means and what
are you thinking about some of these
things
I guess the letter the mysterious
character what's going on with Chad and
Richard I guess those are the are the
pressing questions that this episode
brought up but quite a lot of cool tie
back to things in the past that could
come out and be important later and I am
excited to see where it all leads please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel check out my
other Twin Peaks videos I have a bunch
there's two for this episode that came
out before this and many more please
follow me over on Twitter and on my
other social media accounts let's get
some talking going over there as well
and thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon